c'est tout de même un croix
comme grandissent si vite du berceau as
art puis partir d
deux à quatre pattes à deux pattes et
demi avant de tenir fièrement sur ses
propres de jambes voire même plus tard
se mettre à rouler sur des engins pour
aller toujours et encore plus vite
salut à tous donc je m'appelle adrien
cochet c'est un point de détail ici ce
soir j'ai 24 ans et ce petit bonhomme là
bas c'était moi j'ai pas mal grandi
n'est ce pas bon pour certains jeux
paraît encore un enfant mais tout de
même c'est une première premiers
chiffres pour vous 100% des êtres
vivants grandissent tous et pourtant je
dirais qu'entre nous ici bas ont fait
pas tous la même taille
alors qu'est-ce que grandir
personnellement je considère que je
grandis toujours mais ma taille reste
fixe c'est pourquoi je fais la
distinction entre deux types d'évolution
chez l'humain tout d'abord la croissance
le fait de croître physiquement ou
encore de grandir mais dans le sens à
prendre au travers d'expériences
ça c'est pour ma petite définition et
puis j'ai apporté un ami
ce qu'on va s'intéresser à notre tissu
social et en occurrence mon tout premier
ami qui s'appelle ted et le saviez vous
ted parle
bonjour frais cette blague en anglais
prendra tout son sens donc tu es tu
parles
ou du moins ted parlé dans mon
imaginaire bien entendu mais c'était un
grand compagnon avec qui je me sentais
en confiance n'importe quand n'importe
où et puis l'on ressent il a laissé
place de véritables amis des amis
physique donc à l'âge de 3 ans bah
j'avais autour de moi maximum mon voisin
qui avait deux ans de plus que moi ou
encore jonathan que j'avais rencontré à
la maternelle donc à trois ans mon
cercle relationnel proche était de
composer de mes amis et de ma famille et
puis j'ai un petit frère pierre qui
avait deux ans de moins que moi alors ça
paraît peut-être pas pertinent comme 20
par rapport à tout ce qu'on a entendu
jusqu'ici
pourtant c'est une importance un jour
puisque maxime qui avait deux ans de
plus que moi avait l'expérience à
m'apprendre
je l'attends avec qui j'avais le même
âge ont partagé les mêmes expériences on
apprend t on apprenait au même rythme et
pierre à mon tour je lui ai appris des
choses alors pour illustrer tout ça on
va parler de cas de échelle ccp mais
quoi
alors dfm ccpd fais moi confiance ça
passe on en connaît tous premier exemple
très simple maxime un jour qui me dit
tiens adrien pour faire un record de
saut dans la piscine
c'est très simple tu cours du pile beau
de la terrasse en carrelage à fond à
fond à fond sur la terrasse en carrelage
et tu sautes le plus loin possible fais
moi confiance ça passe deuxième exemple
jonathan sur le vélo il me dit un jour
tian bai adrien pour faire du vélo sans
les mains c'est très facile tu lâches
d'abord une main et très vite la
deuxième je fais ma confiance
ça passe et un dernier avec pierre on
adorait ce serait un peu se battre un
petit peu mais surtout avec des flèches
en plastique ou en mousse et un jour je
perds la dernière flèche et j'ai dit à
pierre je suis vraiment désolé mais
falloir fini cette partie avec ce
pistolet ajout d'une puissance fins
d'exploiter les seuls à billes d'une
puissance de 2 joules fais moi confiance
ça passe à ce moment là on apprend comme
on apprend la méfiance déjà premièrement
et on apprend le courage le fait de
faire parce qu'on a fait confiance à
quelqu'un je dis balle et pourquoi pas
il a peut-être raison de le faire à ce
moment là il ya une expérience que
j'aimerais reprendre c'est celle de
jonathan tu veux parce que finalement ce
vélo bas on n'a pas fait tout à fait ça
sait on en faisait beaucoup
je cours je vivais dans le sud-ouest
petit et on faisait des tours et encore
des tours donc faut comprendre qu'à un
moment effectivement enlever les mains
du guidon ça a été une expérience
majeure et un été où j'étais au canada
mais vers l'étang québécoise
eh ben je suis revenu et là j'attends ça
et faire du vélo sans les mains ouah
mais jonathan apprends-moi faire du vélo
sans les mains et il l'a fait il n'y
tient pas il donne quelques conseils et
en un week-end ça y est moi aussi je
vais faire du vélo sans les mains est-ce
que j'en étais pour un génie pour autant
a pas du tout lui après l'été la wild
thing sauter compagnie moi je me suis
arrêté à enlever les mains ont du coup
c'est bien sûr le prends mon téléphone
quand je fais du vélo c'est de la
pratique mais c'est allé plus loin en
fait content parce que qu'est ce qu'on y
gagne et bah ouais j'ai gagné du temps
mais petit est ce que c'est vraiment
l'intérêt pas forcément mais on peut le
retenir et plus tard en fait c'est juste
que j'ai passé un bon moment avec un
copain et puis
ban au lien de confiance un petit peu
ils sont renforcés à ce moment là
puisque ça a bien marché j'ai entendu le
cas contraire il aurait pu arriver le
moment où je lâche j'écoute rien je
mange un bout de trottoir je deviens un
petit peu frileux de retirer les mains
du guidon pendant un bout de temps et en
même temps de lien de confiance
s'affaiblissent parce qu'il m'avait
pourtant donné des conseils alors c'est
pour ça que j'insiste là dessus
l'expérience on apprend de ces
expériences-là de toujours essayer et
personnellement bassamat quand je vois
ça comme trois autres d'expérience quand
les tests ces zones-là la zone d'angoise
quand on essaye et on est vraiment
stressé comme monter sur une tête une
scène ted c'est un peu stressant ça nous
procure de l'angoissent la zone de
confiance et l'on se dit brooke est là
maintenant j'ai testé plusieurs fois là
c'est bon je me sens à l'aise je monte
sur scène et ça se passe bien et la zone
de confort à tel point qu'on fait on
pourrait peut-être l'expérience qu'on se
sent tout à fait à l'aise en plus de ça
on veut plus prendre de risque et ça
alors ça peut définir aussi bas pourquoi
est-ce que j'ai peur pourquoi est ce que
je me sens à l'aise tout simplement des
foires regarder dans le passé on
comprendra pourquoi dans tout ce que
j'ai à vous donner c'est vrai qu'on est
allé plus loin maintenant dans le
développement de ski et grandir de ce
que je définis d'évoluer mais j'ai pas
fais que ça j'ai fait aussi je me suis
présenté
c'est en résumé je suis adrien 24 ans
franco canadien qui a vécu dans un
village du sud ouest qui traînait plus
tôt avec un ami donc introverti par
choix parce que je mets - lé groupe
d'amis et bat par aman pas si timide que
ça puisque je suis la patrie tremblotant
devant vous finalement il ya un truc
quand même qu'il faut voir c'est que
petit après avoir dit genre oh qu'il est
mignon bascule quand même
oh qu'il est timide effectivement ça le
répète ça le répète qu'il est timide
donc je me dis pas effectivement je suis
timide mais je vais prouver le contraire
je vais essayé de m'exprimer et là on me
répondait articule parle plus fort
bon bah du coup on va essayer autre
chose donc personnellement mon truc pour
me guider bas je pleurais beaucoup
jusqu'à très tard je pleurais je t en
quoi c'est par beaucoup de choses c'est
vrai j'étais nature très stressée et un
rien vous pouvez m'en dressé dès que je
maîtrisais pas bon je peux vous donner
quelques peurs par exemple les montagnes
russes
appelés pour prendre un rendez vous
allez chez le dentiste prendre une
mauvaise note ou encore l'amour des
choses comme ça à voir un jour je me
suis dit je peux plus vivre dans une
zone d'angoise si large
j'ai besoin de vraiment développer et
ouvrir ma zone de confort qui était en
train vélo et les jeux vidéo donc j'ai
fait un jour 15 ans je prend le taureau
par les cornes et je monte dans une
attraction je m'éclate je me fait
balader dans tous les sens c'est génial
finalement je comprend une chose c'est
que mes peurs étaient en majorité tout
irrationnel je fais quoi j'appelle pour
prendre rendez vous chez le coiffeur
je vais chez le dentiste je prends un
moment à deux sur vincent que le monde
autour de moi s'effondre super a dit
rien mais j'ai pas parlé
l'amour par exemple ses relations
interpersonnelles s'agit beaucoup
beaucoup plus de mal à m'en défaire
enfin vraiment m'associer avec du monde
le sociabiliser je restais introverti
très bien pourquoi pas 10 ans je me suis
je peux vivre tranquillement chez moi
j'ai 18 ans j'arrivais en école prépa
intégrée à la fin du bac 2013 quand on
avait trouvé un super studio à
l'extérieur du centre-ville d'orléans
bah voila je peux faire c'est passer mes
soirées sur mon pc à manger devant jeu
pendant un désert trop cool enfin la vie
et les génies et à ce moment là bas mon
cycle encore plus s'il était facile ans
je me levais le matin pour aller en
cours je revenais manger le midi je
repartais en cours et elle sort gens
très joué puis le week-end pareil je
resté enfermé tout le temps et je dis
pas ça par un ou deux week-ends de temps
de pluie je suis resté enfermé non je
reste est vraiment enfermée chez moi
et les rares fois où je suis sorti je
m'appelle d'une fois où je suis allé
chercher des nouvelles paires de
chaussures dans le centre ville
d'orléans jeu raser les murs orléans je
passais y en a beaucoup qui l'ont visité
cette ville mais c'est pas très
inquiétant
il a par la statue de jeanne d'arc ça va
donc failli faire quelque chose encore
une fois là bas j'étais bien accompagné
j'avais une amie qui s'appelait rihab à
ce moment là au relais à quelqu'un à
kiwi c'était un peu difficile de lui
parler à une fille quand même du coup
c'était pas très fluide c'est bloqué
mais finalement ça s'est un peu ouvert
ça commence à se fluidifier à mâcon prix
am a pris le temps de m'accompagner puis
avait une deuxième chose
un projet en fin de l'année où ben j'ai
compris que en tant qu'ingénieur peu
importe le métier que je rêve même de
l'informatique
je serai obligé de collaborer rebelote
l'été 2014
on se dit bon allez on va essayer de
faire un peu plus donc je vais apprendre
à me sociabiliser et h pour une
application toute bête snapshot connaît
bien donc jusqu'au en plus j'arrive à
reprendre contact avec une fille et une
caméra du lycée qui me plaisait pas
match et pas dégueu mais ça se passe
bien super bien donc à ce moment là tant
mieux tant mieux ça se passe et puis
petit à petit gilbert faudrait quand
même qu'on se revoit donc je force un
type je force je force
à tel point qu'à un moment je me fais
bloqués et ben voilà justement ça fait
quand même mais finalement je me suis
aperçu au bout de mon petit bobo tu fais
jeter mais au fil des expériences au fil
des années parfaite j'ai appelé ça du
harcèlement moral dans le sens où numéro
confort de quelqu'un à tel point que la
seule solution c'est de vous bloquez pas
c'est pas c'est pas bon donc c'était un
gros problème est en fait il ya un gros
parallèle entre le moment où je me
sociabilise vraiment je fais de
l'associatif effectivement on a commencé
à en parler j'ai fait président du club
de ski universitaire trésorier du b d e
président d'une association qui ressort
enfin d'une fédération nationale des
étudiants 17500 neiges représentés
n'est-ce là aujourd'hui l'association
des diplômés j'étais entrepreneurs
aujourd'hui actif dans la société
socialement je suis viable je dire si je
veux avoir un tampon c'est viable
je parlerai je vous parle aussi de vent
c'est cool mais il y avait une charge
mentale qui s'accumulaient et dans
toutes les belles histoires parfois il
ya quelques petites horreurs en
l'occurrence pour charger mais pour
vider ma charge mentale
je me suis en taille et les doigts
pendant jusqu'à 1 en différé des petites
coupures
ou encore ben voilà ce côté harcèlement
moral gelé continuer jusqu'à l'année
dernière enfin récemment où il a une
fille avec qui je me plaisais super bien
ça allait bien pareil encore une fois et
finalement pas et on souffre on se dit
ah les beaux gosses étaient un peu
nouveau pour nous deux mais pourquoi pas
à lancer jeudi roma insisté en distance
était quand même important et il ya eu
ce cercle vicieux de je m'énerve je fais
des colères je fais de la jalousie je me
fait pardonner je m'énerve et à la fin
c'est épuisant pour la personne en face
je pense je n'ai pas vécu c'est moi qui
les fais mais c'est très mauvais et
c'est pour ça aujourd'hui j'en parle et
que tout d'un coup je commence à devenir
un peu cynique sur l'attitude de
présentation le titre je rappelle sortir
de sa zone de confiance pour évoluer sa
part est super je dis ah oui
effectivement il ya plein de choses sur
les zones sur la confiance en soi sur le
bien-être sur tout un tas de choses mais
pour apprendre depuis le début c'est ce
que j'en parle
et comme les autres on en parlait aussi
il faut faire et qui fait sans faire
d'erreurs en erreurs
elle est intolérable faire du mal à
quelqu'un on se faire du mal c'est pas
la solution
alors je pose la question effectivement
est-ce que la seule erreur quand on
essaie de se développer quand on essaye
vraiment de sortir de sa zone de confort
c'est se faire du mal ou de faire du mal
aux autres
sincèrement je sais pas et honnêtement
j'espère pas c'est pour ça que j'en
parle ce soir
donc effectivement sortie de zone de
confort allait tenter une nouvelle
expérience mais soyez conscients d'une
chose va au moins respecter deux choses
vous et votre santé d'une part et
d'autre part respecter ceux qui vont
tendre la main qui vous aider et ce à
tout âge même si je pars est tout jeune
et que c'est à dire celle de jeunesse je
pense que ça marche pour tous je pense
vraiment que ça marche pour tous et
c'est pour ça que si on sent pas à
l'aise avec quelque chose si on bloque
finalement peut-être la solution c'est
juste d'être honnête et d'en parler si
on sent pas à l'aise par les ans pour
devenir plus confiant merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]